happened at a Kurdish Community Center I
just want to take you to those live
shots there that we have where you can
see some of the protests that are taking
place people Gathering where a 69 year
old man was arrested after the shooting
that happened in Paris officials say
that he was already known to the
authorities and it's reported that he
tried to attack a Migrant Center last
year well as you're currently looking at
you can see protest protesters taking to
the streets near the scene of the attack
the French interior Minister also
visited the scene he said that
demonstrations against the shooting
would be allowed to take place but you
can see there crowds Gathering
outside the scene of that shooting well
let's bring in our Europe correspondent
Siobhan Robbins at who's following this
story Siobhan what can you tell us
well as you can see from the live
pictures coming out of Paris at the
moment extremely angry scenes on the
streets they're happening just around
the corner we could hear when the
interior Minister visited in the last
hour
um much louder chance that seemed to be
when that anger really bubbled over it's
not exactly clear what those
demonstrators are currently demanding
but clearly extremely angry following
this shooting that happened today just
to give you some more background on what
happened is in the 10th District of
Paris so quite a busy Central Area
Multicultural area and we understand
that a gunman targeted a Kurdish
cultural center and shot at least six
people we know three of those people
have died now we understand from
prosecutors that the gunman himself was
injured he's got wounds to his face and
is currently being treated in hospital
but this was someone who was on the
radar of the police he had been detained
before for attacks on a Paris migrant
camp with a saber we're told by
prosecutors in 2021. now it was
interesting because when the interior
Minister walked those streets in the
last hour he did say although he has
known to the authorities he wasn't on
the radar of the security services and
also he said that although he was on the
police radar that he wasn't on the radar
for politically motivated attacks so
really the investigations are continuing
there in Paris we heard from authorities
that they're still keeping an open mind
about what the motive was but they are
looking at whether this was a racially
motivated attack but very tense scenes
in the capital there ahead of Christmas
are you talking about the ten scenes and
we can certainly see it on our screens
right now something appearing to be
burning in the street there you can hear
the sort of shouting chanting from
people who were gathering in Paris too
as you say really can show their anger
and it's as you you're talking there
won't you about how it's unclear what
exactly they are demanding but it's not
the first time is it that we've seen
this kind of violence in Paris and
perhaps dissatisfaction with the
authorities as well
no um if we are honest about it violence
between police and various groups of
protests happen extremely frequently in
France I've been in France myself for a
football events for example the police
are use tear gas quite routinely they
also use pepper spray as well we've seen
tear gas being shot today but as we say
today we don't know exactly what those
people are demanding they're clearly
very very angry the interior Minister
making it clear when he visited that
those demonstrations would be allowed to
continue so they're not trying to clear
people off the streets in that sense but
we can see that the police are very
quick to move in with more aggressive
crowd control there that they have been
using
um tear gas and pepper spray at the
moment though it doesn't seem to be
clearing people from those streets and
it is quite regular that we see these
type of fights back and forth between
groups of protesters and police in the
capital
you can see you know the police sort of
moving in there with shields with also
their own sort of personal protection as
well that fine balance of course between
allowing people to show that anger and
to protest at the scene of what happened
earlier Siobhan thank you very much
indeed we'll stay across those pictures
in Paris for you